- Why are you making that face?
- I'm doing a little Romeo eyes with it.
- Are you, what is this?
- I'm bar-b-quin'.
We barbecue it.
(both laughing)
(hip hop instrumentals)
- So today we're here to try rap snacks.
I have never heard of it
but apparently it's a very black thing.
- Black in business?
- I'm hella excited for sure.
I wanna see what the
Migos joints taste like.
I feel like it gotta be fire.
- I'm excited for these rap snacks.
- Me too.
- Let's bring it on.
(hip hop beats)
- Oh yeah!
- The Migos Rap Snacks
with a dab of ranch.
Oh, this is where they made the verse,
"The dab of ranch."
- Dab of ranch.
There it is, there it is.
- There we go.
- It's a little sweeter
than I expected it but
- I'm tasting the dab.
- It's a larger dab than I thought.
- Yeah, I didn't think I was gonna...
So it's definitely more of
like, less of a whisper,
but more like a dab.
These motherfuckers is dab.
- No, it ain't bad.
- I had like a ham sandwich, and you put,
you put this on a ham
sandwich like a cream soda.
- I'd give this two mics only
because I'm not a sour cream kinda girl.
- I wanna give 'em a four.
I'm not mad at this.
- I feel like we should just
put them all in the corner.
- Yeah, Imma have to jump back into those.
Oh, we gon' dip right into the lil Romeos.
- Why Romeo?
That's the question.
Let's really talk about this.
You got all these rappers
and you chose Romeo.
Why?
Nobody recognize his face.
- Looks like they (laughing).
- Bar-b-quin' with my honey. (laughing)
- Why do these say bar-b-quin'?
Whatchu say?
We barbecue it.
(both laughing)
- Oh yeah, maybe it'll just
taste like barbecue chips.
- It's like, I don't want
just like, sweet barbecue,
I taste the honey but I
don't taste the barbecue.
- I love this, this is refreshing.
- Aight, well.
I'm not gonna lie.
This shit's better than Migos joints.
- I like this.
- I give five mics, for sure.
I could finish a bag.
- Imma give five too.
- I ain't giving Romeo one mic, I'm sorry.
- Wow!
Like his album.
- Trash like them lyrics.
(both laughing)
- Boosie bad ass.
- Alright, look, look, look, look.
This is a bag with character.
- Louisiana heat, ooou!
I'm so excited, I bet it's spicy.
- This is really good.
- This motherfucker might get a five.
- Yeah?
- This has five mics.
This is a perfect chip.
- Yeah, man.
It got that nice spice to it.
- Everything about this is right.
- I give this three mics
coz it was spicy and I like spicy
but it is, it didn't have a flavor.
- I give it a four.
- As a girl who never tried
rap snacks, I'm here for this.
I would definitely buy
them, they're only a dollar.
- I'd definitely buy those again.
Those are good.
- Yeah.
- I fucks with these chips.
- I hope these chips fuck with me.
(hip hop instrumentals)